welcome everyone from Columbia
University key books on game theoretic
techniques and computer science and
today he's gonna be telling us about
some of its applications all right
thanks very much good morning everyone
thanks for showing up early I want to
talk today about two results concerning
incentives in blockchains
so I'm very interested incentive
compatibility so in a blockchain context
that would mean you know is the protocol
designed to properly motivate the
participants to build but behave in the
way that it's intended and I'm
particularly interested in techniques
from a field of economics called
mechanism design and technology transfer
between the two so before I talk about
either either the two specific results
let me just tell you a couple slides
about like the big dream what I would
you know what I hope to see happen
all right so mechanism design is often
described as inverse game theory so what
is game theory so this is you know where
you study Nash equilibria and that kind
of thing so you set up who are the
strategic actors you know so in our
contacts that context that might be for
example the miners you have to specify
what actions are available to them so
that might be like honest mining plus
various deviations and you have to
specify their payoffs you know for
example what's the mining reward earned
by the miner okay so that's you set up a
game and traditionally game theory is
descriptive okay so you set up a
mathematical model of your strategic
situation you identify its equilibria
again like Nash equilibria and then you
draw inferences about your game based on
its equilibrium so mechanism design like
I said is inverse game theory meaning
what meaning you don't actually start
with a game in mechanism design you
start with a desired outcome okay and
then you put on your engineers hat and
you try to reverse engineer a game in
which that desired outcome is in fact an
equilibrium okay so this general idea
you know sort of designing the rules of
the game to incentivize people to behave
you know to lead to a particular outcome
I hope that sounds like super relevant
for blockchain protocol design again I
think it is
I'm particularly interested in
technology transfer between the two both
in terms of specific technical tools the
mechanism design might offer but also
you know it's a pretty mature theory and
so I think it can offer a kind of
blueprint of what we might hope a theory
of incentive compatibility in
blockchains might look like say 10 years
from now so what's so great about
mechanism design what have they done you
know over the past many decades well
let's start really simple
I mean they've articulated sort of the
appropriate design space so if you walk
up to a random mechanism designer on the
streets and you use the phrase the space
of all mechanisms that mechanism
designer will actually know what you
mean and a precise and mathematical
sense and would it be great if we had
some proposed definitions for what the
space of all blockchain protocols might
mean okay those are definitions that we
still lack now once you've articulated
the design space all kinds of doors open
up so for example you can do
optimization over your design space so
positive metric that you care about and
ask is there a protocol which is optimal
with respect to that metric maybe
subject to some constraints and now once
once you're sort of in the optimization
mindset and exploring the design space
just inevitably it leads you to new
points in that design space you hadn't
considered before you know with the
focus provided by a by an objective
function so I think ultimately this
exercise you know should lead us to some
new and interesting protocol designs as
well so that's kind of the high level
you know the big dream kind of what I'm
interested in this talk is going to be
about sort of two different places where
I took a really tiny bite-sized piece of
the overall puzzle and applied this
mindset so the the sort of the settings
will be fairly narrow but in exchange we
will be rewarded with very crisp
mathematical results so the the first
thing I want to talk about is an
axiomatic approach to black rewards this
is joint work with a couple of my
columbia colleagues c chen and christos
papadimitriou and this i just presented
this in zurich on Tuesday at the AFT
conference so you can analyze incentives
and blockchain protocols at various time
scales and in this paper we're going to
look at sort of the simplest imaginable
timescale okay that of a single epoch
that are the creation of a single block
okay most of the most incentive of
famous incentive attacks on block chains
operate at longer timescales like
selfish mining for example that
about miners deviating over a period of
multiple epochs not just one in this
paper we're focusing just on a single
block creation okay so what kind of
design decision do you even face at the
level of sort of a single block well
we're gonna be interested in how the
reward for the block is distributed to
the miners so I'm thinking about a
proof-of-work typesetting like Bitcoin
and when a bottle and I'm when a block
is created I'm assuming there's some
reward that needs to be distributed to
the miners could be a block reward could
be transaction fees whatever okay
there's just some amount of currency
that needs to be allocated to back to
the miners now as a proof-of-work
blockchain
what is this distribution going to be a
function of it's going to be a function
of the computational power that the
different miners bring to the table
okay so the miners various hash rates so
it's a function of the hash rates the
miners contributes we're looking at the
design decision of how do you
redistribute the rewards once you've
successfully authorized a block yeah so
again I mean I think I'll become clear
exactly what my desiderata are so you
know we're gonna be going towards stuff
like you know what are what do you need
to be Sybil proof or collusion proof
those are gonna be the kind of questions
I'm getting to so again all this stuff
about like you know so again like
forking attacks it doesn't even make
sense for this first part of the talk
because we're just looking at the time
scale of a single block yeah so it's
gonna be incentive issues that are
probably different than most of the
issues you've seen in the blockchain
space yeah so again it's it's sort of
simpler but again there's a reward as
you'll see we'll sort of really be able
to nail the question okay so that's
that's the design decision we're going
to look at miners bring a bunch of hash
weights to the table a block gets
created there's some reward to be
distributed how do you do it well how is
it done now what I want you to think
about the way it's done now is what I'm
gonna call the proportional allocation
rule okay which just means that in an
expected sense the block reward is
distributed amongst the miners
proportional to their hash rates okay so
if you bring 20% of the hash rate to the
table then your expected reward in this
epoch is going to be 0.2 times whatever
the reward is associated with this block
okay so that's what I mean with a
proportional allocation rule you
distribute the war is proportional to
miners hash rates the point of this
first paper is to ask can we do better
what else could we do
is there any reason why we would want to
do something else than proportionate
allocation
so to investigate this question I need
to say you know what are the
alternatives what are we allowed to do
other than this sort of proportional
redistribution and so you know in
general yeah yeah it's not defined yet
so in it so I should say in any sense so
can we do better in some sense or
alternatively can we prove that the
proportional rule is optimal in some
sense okay any sense I'd be pretty happy
about okay so those are the two
successful outcomes as far as I'm
concerned asking this question yeah so
this is deafening not defined yet
okay so what's the design space I'm
going to look at okay so I'm just gonna
look at all I'm gonna call them
allocation rules so an allocation rule
is just a function it takes as input a
tuple of miners hash rates and its
output is a tuple of the same length of
the expected block rewards that get you
know distributed to the miners just a
function so at the moment I haven't set
up a strategic situation so we're just
think about these functions from hash
rates to rewards later we'll ask you
know what properties might we want these
to satisfy and that's when the
incentives will come in so good so
proportion allocation rule that's
obviously one example of an allocation
rule but of course there's many other
functions one could write down okay now
in our context in this reward
redistribution context it's natural to
focus on what are called budget balanced
allocation rules which just means the
protocol distributes all of the reward
that it has to distribute nothing more
nothing less
so after scaling I'm just going to say
that the expected rewards given to the
miners sum to one you could look at
variations you could look at so-called
week budget balance where the protocol
can keep some of the reward for itself
but for the most part will focus on the
stronger the sort of exact budget
balance case okay so this is this is
what else is allowed now should have
this you know you might say that's fine
as a mathematical definition but if you
think about implementation you might say
well what's the meaning of this right
does the proof-of-work framework kind of
force us to do the proportional
allocation rule but I mean after all you
know if a miner has twenty percent of
the computational power under the random
Oracle assumption there's simply 20
percent likely to be the first one to
solve the crypto puzzle okay and so but
what I want to what I want to argue next
is that at least in principle it within
a proof-of-work context you could
implement pretty much any allocation
rule that you want
but the budget balance does it capture
of this strategic money where you see I
wanna be mine because there's a new
perceptions going to be much more so the
time scale is that of a single block so
I'm not thinking about say a forking
attack I'm not thinking about the time
skill multiple blocks so for example
forking attacks are sort of not part of
the vocabulary of this model I said good
okay so I'm just yeah so I'm not I'm not
modeling the different minders might
choose different blocks to propose with
different transaction amounts for
example assume I'm just going to assume
that the minors I mean some ways it's
not gonna matter right so think about
the proportional rule that tells you how
to redistribute it whatever the reward
winds up being so it's true I've sort of
set it up as if it's kind of ex ante but
it really accepts post but it's not
going to matter yeah thanks for the
question so again I haven't set up the
strategic situation yet so I would think
of the actions as basically whether or
not you Sybil attack and whether or not
you collude ultimately that's where
we're going so that's what you just have
a hash rate then you just come to the
table with a hash rate about your
machines and so we're not modeling
investment you just have some hash rate
we don't know H 1 and H n we can think
over time as the more the more blocks
you you submit do you have what if I
want to do for example square time and
increase Europe if you have many many
times exactly that's exactly the second
half of the slot exactly right yeah yes
so it's related to mining pools the
second half of the talk will be squarely
about money pools let me finish let me
finish I'm gonna say about this slide I
think that'll head off a lot of the
questions ok so again remember where we
were I said you know does the
proof-of-work setup force us to do the
proportional allocation role and I'm
about to argue that you know at least
principal no I'm not saying we should
implement something other than a
proportional rule but if we really
wanted to we could okay the reason is
the law of large numbers okay so I want
you to think about the way Bitcoin works
now is that in each epoch it takes a
single sample from a probability
distribution the distribution that's
proportional to miners hash rates okay
you sample at once that's sort of your
leader election you know that's whoever
proposes the block and collects the
forward Ward alternatively we could take
a thousand samples or ten thousand
samples from that distribution at which
point as was suggested we would have a
very accurate estimate of exactly what
miners cash rate was over that period
and once you actually do know the H sub
i's you can implement whatever reward
scheme you want the selected Vino does
not just drop all the samples that's
slowly a spell let's imagine they're on
chain for example imagine you publish
partial solutions to the chain okay I
sort of wanted I want to all right let
me say a little bit more about the
implementation here so the next question
might be you know how would you get
these thousand samples or 10,000 samples
and this is where the connection I'm not
saying is the only way you can implement
it but one way you can implement it is
the same way
this kind of thing is done in mining
pools which again we'll talk a lot about
in the second half of the talk which is
you know in you know in addition to sort
of having your difficult crypto puzzle
you have an easier version of the crypto
puzzle where you expect solutions to be
found at a much higher rates one
thousand thousand times it's frequently
or ten thousand times as frequently and
then once the difficult crypto puzzle is
found at that point you have these other
thousand or ten thousand samples from
the same hash rate distribution
completion
but there are protocols to work based on
protocol that there are quite a few of
them already prism and Yahoo ghost base
you know dampers protocols even
aetherium rewards all my blocks so not
only the main leader block gets rewards
in many of these so I'm looking at a
model where there's a reward associated
atomically with each block and that's
what you're responsible for
redistributing I'm not claiming I'm
modeling all protocols in the world yeah
the whole point here is to say you know
can we can we take a bite-sized piece of
the puzzle and get something that's
really crisp as a conclusion yes so you
said we could model all mechanisms but
there is a problem with basically
estimating this couple of identity hash
trade because I think any mechanism that
would allow you to get a benefit by
actually splitting her identity
potentially cannot be that's exactly
where we're going actually
so Sybil attacks is gonna be something I
care about so right now the miners are
just identified by public keys so there
absolutely could be symbols out there I
think that's like that's again what's
gonna be the main okay good so again
point of the slide proportional rules
how it's done you know in principle if
we really were motivated we can
implement other rules as well if nothing
else by doing this multiple sampling
trick like you see in mining pools okay
so that's the question I want to study
okay so this is our design space all
possible budget balanced allocation
rules proportional is one example you
write down a number of other functions
is there any reason you might want to
deviate from the proportional rule so
we're going to attack this using the
axiomatic approach okay which is a tried
and true sort of method for reasoning
about design problems in economics so
it's a two-step recipe so in step one
you kind of gather up the courage to
write down some formal you know
requirements for your allocation okay
what you want and the second step you
investigate the consequences of the
conditions you wrote down is there
anything in the design space that
satisfies all of those conditions and if
so what are they okay
so we had in mind role models like you
know just sort of basic classical
expected utility theory where you
characterize utility based on axioms
over consistency of people's preferences
over lotteries you know arrows
impossibility theorem of social choice
which is when you have at least three
candidates there's no you know voting
rule which satisfies a natural set of
three axioms or in cooperative game
theory of Shapley characterized to
Shapley value as the unique value
satisfying a particular list of four
axioms so those are the kinds of things
we were hoping to follow in the
footsteps of and you know why do this
well one of the big benefits of the
axiomatic approach and the uniqueness
and impossibility results that you wind
up getting is it really clarifies what
kind of compromises you're going to need
to make in your design problem so for
example in arrows theorem it's an
impossibility theorem does that mean
nobody ever runs an election with three
or more candidates of course not we run
them all the time it just clarifies any
way you do it will violate one of three
conditions you would want to have and it
is then up to you to pick one of those
three which of those three axioms you're
most comfortable violating and then
designing designing accordingly so that
in my opinion is really the way to think
about these types of axiomatic results
sort of saying what are the fundamental
compromises you will need to make in
your design problem in this case
fundamental compromises for deviating
from the proportional allocation rule
okay so we're gonna have three axioms
for the first two let me sort of
introduce them by proposing a crazy
allocation rule that's not proportional
and we're gonna hate all the proposals
then we're gonna make precise the sense
in which we hate the proposals and those
will turn into axioms okay example
number one the uniform allocation rule
you take every minor you know about Oh
get all the public keys
you choose one uniformly at random and
that's your leader election protocol
okay they create the block they create
the whole they collect the whole block
of work how do we feel about that we
hate it
the body we hate it because it totally
misses the points of a permissionless
blockchain setting where civil attacks
are cheap if this was your allocation
rule you would absolutely create
multiple identities because each
identity would then have its own
probability of winning and making you
the leader in collecting the whole
reward so don't like this because it's
not because it's that it's vulnerable to
simple attacks we're gonna reject all
other protocols that are similarly
vulnerable to civil attacks which brings
us to axiom number one which is simple
proof this which says what you would
think it would say it says if a miner
ever splits themselves up into a bunch
of Sybil's whose combined hash rate is
that most what they started with that
minor ones up only worse off okay
so formally if you start with some hash
rate vector H and one of the miners
splits themselves up into a bunch again
and again they can't make up hash rate
from nowhere so that some of their
Sybil's hash rates is amost what they
had at the beginning then they're at
least as well-off but for the simple
attack as they were after the subliminal
proof so fine next one here's another
crazy allocation rule winner-take-all
where you give the entire block reward
always to the biggest miner okay so
suppose you've taken your thousand or
10,000 samples you know who the biggest
miner is with high probability and you
give them the whole block reward every
single for every I the reward is higher
than the total reward well then the
tougher we want divided by the side of
math right because because everyone in S
represents you right so you split
yourself into s they each get their
reward right so this is the sum and this
is also the sum right so the combined
hash rate of your symbols is at most
what your hash rate was and you want the
total reward to your symbols to be at
most where your original reward I see
yes like really it's because of the
unfairness right not because like it was
more fair fair then maybe you wouldn't
have well I mean so if you were
rewarding proportionately and I should
have said this early
earlier the proportional role certainly
is Sibylle proof right so if you're a
miner with 20% of the hash rate and you
split into two ten percent miners it
does not change the expected reward
you're going to earn okay so you don't
you don't from
okay so we need to define fairness and I
don't want to define fairness is
proportionality right I want to derive
proportionality as the unique solution
to some other set of criteria and so
that's why I like I deliberately want
the axioms to be weak because that's
what gives my uniqueness result force so
I don't to tell you I mean I'm looking
at the looking at incentives that the at
the time scale of a single block okay so
I wanna I want to avoid Sybil attacks
for example at the level of a single
block
I am just claiming that we might be
unhappy with protocols that failed to
satisfy this axiom that is the only
argument I'm making on the slide
okay so that's actually in one you want
to be civil proof if you can get
yourself in arbitrarily many parts in a
costliest fashion and then the sum of
what you get in every single game is
more than the sum what you got before
like so I'm just saying the negation of
your thing then there's a problem right
because people will split in many pieces
that's exactly I mean so that is the one
thing I'm asking you to go along with me
with on this slide so I'm asking you to
I'm asking you to agree that it's worth
thinking about rules that don't suffer
from simple attacks I'm not I don't even
I'm not claiming it's a fundamental
axiom but it's going to be this axiom
for the next axiom well so good it kind
of is sort of neutral I would say on
centralization and then the other axioms
also we'll sort of see how that goes but
I mean civil attacks and centralization
kind of push against each other and it's
gonna be unusually kind of vividly
illustrated in the main result today
right like you've sort of assumed cash
rate means identity here I'm assuming
you can you know I'm assuming you are
aware of public keys and that you can
count say the number of partial
solutions that people have submitted
according to their public key so these
vectors are indexed by public keys not
by identity it's the number of public
keys that you are aware of so if there
was a cost to introducing a new public
key then I
be sealed proof and not by legal axiom
right and that's an excellent point so
you know remember I talked about one of
the reasons for this exercise to clarify
sort of compromises and if for example
you know you were in a permissioned
world and you didn't have to worry about
civil attacks then you're gonna be able
to escape the uniqueness result that I'm
going to present in a couple slides ok
so but the theorem that I'm going to
stay for you will assume that you don't
like civil attacks in this sense I'm not
saying that's always going to be true
but certainly there are cases where it's
gonna be true
all right so that's a simple proof this
no one should be able to gain from a
civil attack second crazy allocation
rule winner-take-all give the whole
block or do the biggest minor okay if
you think about it okay so how do you
feel about this probably your gut
reaction is this is nuts also notice it
is Sybil proof right if you only reward
the biggest minor you're never gonna you
know do better by shattering yourself in
a small minor so it's problematic but
for a different reason what is the
reason it's because of the sort of
unstoppable force towards centralization
that this creates
if you implemented this what on earth
would miners do other than form a 51%
pool guarantee themselves that reward
okay it's just a very strong force
toward collusion so we're gonna reject
winner-take-all on the basis of this
push toward centralization toward
collusion so that gives us our second
axiom collusion proof nets okay which
says that whenever you have a hash rate
vector and a bunch of the you know
public keys band together and form a
single sort of merge into a single minor
then the reward that that merge single
minor receives should not be any larger
than what all of those miners were
receiving collectively before they
colluded about to minors collude the
obviously their combined hash rate is at
most the sum of the hash rates they
started with and it should not be better
off the rule roared that the single
merged minor gets is in most what they
got collectively in the first place we
only need one more accident straight
that when we get to the definition
that's the best place to illustrate it
always you make no assumption about how
they'll split that's high that's an
excellent question so the question is
you know what's the side payment
structure within the coalition and
actually if you look in the paper it's
sort of a subtle point and we have three
different definitions for the uniqueness
result it's actually gonna be true for
the weakest of the definitions so we're
at so we're actually going to work we're
gonna for the theorem we're going to
assert we're
okay sort of we're gonna allow basically
arbitrary transfers within a coalition
okay and actually no so we have even
weaker versions sorry I don't want to
get into the three different flavors but
you have to define that okay pretty much
for it pretty much you got the same
results no matter how you define it
either arbitrary internal transfers or
proportional internal transfers doesn't
matter for the results okay yeah so so
Jing rightfully asked do we really need
an axiom three and we do I mean it's not
you know it is what it is anonymity or
you might also call it symmetry this
just says that your allocation rule
should not use the name of a minor in
deciding what its reward should be what
would be an example of a non-anonymous
allocation rule take the
lexicographically smallest public key
you've ever heard of and give them the
whole block reward it's obviously crazy
you never do it but that's an example of
something that satisfies those first two
it's why we need another axiom so in
other words a rule can differentiate
between different miners only in as much
as they contribute different hash rates
to the protocol so those are three
axioms so another way of saying it is if
you permute the vector of hash rates the
rewards get commuted in exactly the same
way that's that's another way to define
it so to avoid this issues we encourage
you to think of it as a proof-of-work
chain if it is proof of stake actually
the results still going to be still
going to hold if the rewards depend only
on the current amount of stake you have
as opposed to more detailed aspects of
the history but you do allow randomized
algorithms yes because for example one
would be we run a lottery that he's need
or the BRS on the name and that's okay
that's not reusing
right yes correct correct
good point say this is necessary because
you are in this is Sybil proof and
solution it sounds like if I use this
rule I want to create us yes so there's
sort of another attack vector so I mean
that's just to prove the point that
there do exist non-anonymous rules so I
don't want I don't want to go through
sort of a detailed proof of exactly what
it is but like I mean I just want you to
internalize what i'm disallowing with
the anonymity assumption and that is the
kind of thing that i'm disallowing
that's the only point to take away from
this okay just let me just a theorem so
you can all look at it and then i can
take some more questions so I promise
the uniqueness result and indeed the
proportion of roll as we've discussed we
discuss it's Sybil proof it's obviously
coalition proof if to 10 percent miners
collude and become 20 percent miner
doesn't change their expected rewards
it's evidently anonymous and in fact it
is the unique budget balanced rule that
satisfies all three of those conditions
I don't believe so
you can weaken anonymity to what's
called equal treatment of equals I'll
have to skip the proof probably but if
we did the proof you would see that
really all that matters is that if two
hash two miners have exactly the same
hash rate they should get exactly the
same reward
maybe yeah in the collusion axiom what
you hated is slightly different from
what you doesn't laugh right so what you
what it's clearly what you said we
should hate these okay you know
winner takes all but maybe saying we
have a target set of winners let's say a
thousand let's say ten thousand here we
can argue what that number should be
it's not something we would hate so much
and would actually violate excellent
point and so and again I think this is
one of the big benefits of sort of this
whole exercise right so we we wind up
somewhere right with this uniqueness
theorem and then you know we could do
two things we could we could celebrate
you say well this is how we do it and
it's giving us a precise sense in which
is a good way to do it or you could say
no I want to be more creative I want to
do something else and then this got it
so this is guiding you to exactly the
right question how do we take one of the
actions relax it keep it reasonable but
let the design space blossom a little
bit and have more than just the single
point so this is exactly the starting
point for those kinds of investigations
let's see right so I guess I just said
this right so one one interpretation is
as a prescriptive result saying you
really should do proportional sharing I
think of this as more just like if you
want to deviate from it now you
understand sort of what what what you
have to what you have to drop okay I
think I'm gonna skip the proof
25 minutes okay because the proof is not
hard just a couple slides so I'll go
ahead and go ahead and show it to you I
should say I just found out last week
that this basically exact same result
was proved independently by Jacob lush
know who's right here in the audience
and speaking later today at Chicago and
also Philips track at at Yale okay all
right so the proof how we do it so for
the exposition
I'm going to assume that all of the
minor hash rates are positive integers
okay 1 2 3 etc by scaling an irrational
hash rates would be fine for this
theorem the proof no surprise it's going
to be by induction by induction on what
well first thought might be you know
maybe by induction on the number of
minors actually I winds have been kind
of annoying right because we're thinking
about these Sybil attacks and we're
thinking about these collusive attacks
and then the number of minors changes
under those attacks which can kind of
mess up applying the inductive
hypothesis so instead the correct
inductive parameter it turns out is the
number of minors which contribute a hash
rate of larger than the minimum ok the
minimum here is 1 so the number of
minors that contribute a hash rate of 2
or more it turns out once you have this
inductive parameter the rest of the
proof writes itself and you basically
just watch with satisfaction is the
teamwork between the three axioms builds
up to the result that you want in a
natural
all right base case what is base case
that means there's no minors
contributing more than the minimum so we
have an all ones vector of some length
okay now anonymity remember that says
you can differentiate between minors
only in as much as they have different
hash rates so for the all ones vector
they all have to get exactly the same
reward budget balance which says the sum
of the rewards equals one so we even
know what that common reward has to be
it has to be 1 over the number of minors
which in the base case is also 1 over
the total hash rate ie the proportional
allocation rule so that's when there's
no minors contributing more than the
minimum let's look at when there's one
or more say T minors with hash rate
bigger than 1 pick one of them
arbitrarily call it minor I okay capital
H denotes the total hash rate to cases
we're gonna see that simple proofing
this kind of imposes a lower bound on
payments and collusion proof this
imposes an upper bound on payments and
proportional is the only thing that's
gonna thread the needle kind of as was
suggested by the audience so case one
the rule tries to get away with under
paying this minor relative to what it
would obtain under the proportional rule
well in this case this is an opportunity
for a civil attack minor I if it wants
could break itself into h sub i's
Sybil's each with hash rate one call
that vector H prime notice an H prime
the number of minors has gone up but the
number of minors with more than the
minimum hash rate has gone down putting
us into the inductive hypothesis this is
exactly why we set it up the way we did
the inductive hypothesis applies to H
prime it has to be proportional on that
vector so in particular each of those
Sybil's gets reward 1 over capital H
there was H sub I Sybil's so
collectively they get H sub I over
capital H which is more than what minor
I was getting before the civil attack in
other words this vector H witnesses the
failure of civil proof Ness this
particular rule
it can be rational member yeah I mean it
needs a little extra argument but it's a
boring argument so I'm gonna skip it all
right so that's that's where simple
proof neskowin to play so case two very
similar suppose the rule tries to get
away with overpaying minor I okay paying
more than little H to buy over capital H
well now think of H prime okay the same
H prime is before after the civil attack
but now imagine those actually aren't
Sybil's imagine all those hash rate
one-liners are bonafide miners okay now
starting from H prime that set of hash
rate one-liners I have an incentive to
collude because if they if they colluded
and then went back they would get this
so what's so sorry first of all so in H
prime what are they getting each of the
symbols is getting 1 over capital H ok
so collectively they're getting little H
sub I over capital H if they colluded
then they would get back to what this
rule is giving them which is bigger than
that ok little H sub I over capitulation
proof miss comes
so proportional is all that remains the
proof so far seems also to really rely
on this anonymity and not many to
department right it's not a wise woman
you're forming a group
certainly author I mean all three axioms
are necessary in the sense that I can
give you examples of non-proportional
rules that satisfy each pair of the
three and moreover I mean certainly if
you look at the proof it's very clear
that each of them plays a essential role
in the proof and that's it you said the
proof so far but that's actually that's
the whole purpose oh so we're done
you say it again if the threshold
like election this is what you're saying
goats go back to winner-take-all you're
saying you're saying generalized
winner-take-all so that there can be
multiple winners right is that the
nature of the proposal yeah so so right
so I mean this was sort of like the
discussion we had before so you will
violate one of the axioms maybe and
yours in your application it's going to
be in a way that you can tolerate it so
tell me the rule exactly I think some
computing power I don't want you know
people sitting here and mining so I'm
taking some computing power and just pay
for something higher so that threshold
will become your one basically yeah but
you pay one and I say that's not pay for
people with once you come once you join
you don't have incentive to join
infinity but that's which acts M is
violates right it violates the collision
proof miss one because you'll be
occluded to get above the threshold
exactly as was proposed yeah
okay other questions about the about the
proof
right so the paper has a couple
variations you know maybe I'll just
mention one so you could think about
relaxing budget balance two-week budget
balance so this is the case where the
protocol is allowed to keep some of the
reward for itself if it wants what could
you do with that extra flexibility well
I guess a trivial thing you could do is
you could scale the proportional rule
and still satisfy the three axioms like
always keep half of it for yourself
distribute the other half proportionally
more generally you could scale by
different constants at different times
okay so we call a generalized
proportional allocation rule as a scaled
version of the proportional rule where
the scaling factor depends only on the
sum of the contributed hash rates and
moreover it needs to be a non decreasing
function that the summit contributed
hash rates its definition it you don't
have to remember this definition the
point is just you know you can again use
this exact same methodology to exactly
characterize which rules satisfy the
three axioms and a weekly budget balance
and it is precisely these okay every
rule of this form no matter what
non-decreasing f you pick does indeed
satisfy all three axioms any rule which
is not of this form violates at least
one so again this is kind of showing
that you know setting is narrow right
but the things you can prove are very
sharp
last thing I want to say about this in
this first part of the talk I'll talk a
little bit about risk aversion so I've
been glossing that sort of shoving this
under the rug all along of assuming that
minors are risk neutral meaning in
difference between having a 20% chance
of getting the entire block reward or
having a 20-bit starting a hundred
percent chance of getting point two
times the brach award so far I've been
assuming that those are exactly the same
thing now you look out there in the
world and there's a lot of evidence that
miners are not actually risk neutral and
we'll sort of again expand on this in
the second part mining pools are a
pretty strong suggestion that there's
risk aversion among miners mining pools
act as insurance policies smoothing out
your reward lowering the variance and
having a steady or payout so I view that
that the the assumption of risk
neutrality is not a very good one in
this setting there's a standard way to
talk about risk-averse decision-makers
using expected utility theory you just
set it up so that miners are now going
to act to maximize not their expected
reward but their expected utility of
their reward where that utility function
is strictly concave function likes like
the square root function of the
logarithm function again all this is
saying is that all else being equal
agents strictly prefer more certainty to
less certainty that's sort of the role
of risk aversion and unfortunately that
uniqueness results that we had becomes
an impossibility results at least for
the standard randomized implementation
of the proportional rule randomized
implementation I mean you put one sample
from the hash rate distribution that one
miner collects the whole reward so that
version of the implementation it does
not no longer satisfies collusion proof
Nassif have risk averse miners you have
a 10% miner and another 10% miner they
actually wanna collude form a 20% pool
split the proceeds
equally it keeps their expectation the
same lowers their variance so higher
expected utility so you lose collusion
proof news with risk aversion with the
randomized implementation they have
something you could do again at least in
principle is you could do a near
deterministic implementation of this
exact same allocation rule okay where
you again take your thousand samples or
10,000 samples to learn everyone's hash
rates and that
deterministically split the block reward
fractionally amongst the miners
according to their hash rates which you
now know this is a deterministic reward
rule essentially okay now with
deterministic rewards there is no
difference between being risk neutral or
being risk averse it's exactly the same
thing so you actually recover the
collusion proof in this from our risk
neutral analysis if you do this you know
kind of exotic deterministic
implementation of the proportional rule
is the granularity with which you need
to measure these trait related to that's
a good question yes I would say you
could work out that trade-off if you
wanted so I mean so in some sense I mean
if the utility functions are very can
change very sharply then small errors in
the hash rate estimation could be
problematic
is that not what's happening in the
world like the mining pools - oh sorry I
I thank you I had more to say here which
I totally forgotten actually so how
should you think about this okay so
first of all the reviewer pointed out to
us that if you look at the the fruit
chain protocol and you look at it was
sort of the right parameter settings
it's actually more or less simulating
kind of exactly this kind of idea and
another way to think about it is
basically we've taken what historically
happens in a mining pool as you said and
we've rotted into the protocol itself
you basically put it on chain so at
least for a mechanism designed nerd like
me there's an amusing metaphor with
what's called the revelation principle
of Mecca and mechanism design which says
there's a sort of generic way to turn
non truthful mechanisms and the truthful
mechanisms by taking the deviations
agents would have done and bringing them
into the mechanism itself and it's
basically exactly sort of what's
happening here bringing the mining pool
into the protocol so that there's no
longer a need for that for a individual
miner which seems to be true but there's
a risk still have to be someone is
taking the risk suppose you form a port
and a lot of people are working on it
the entire post you have remaining risks
somewhere and if you give all these
miners deterministic good payoff so this
has to be the manager is taking them
well so at this point there's literally
no manager anymore right assuming is
basically there's a let the manager take
the risk while there is a single pool in
this case there's a single port ended up
working overtime I'm not following
what's the minors for yeah well I mean
people in the audience who could answer
that better than me but I thought I view
it that there's kind of a gentlemen's
agreement in effect so cultural norms
would be another way to talk about it
yeah I thought I'd say like if you
implement that we're gonna take all rule
all bets will be off in my opinion the
questions that's the first part of the
top
so
but you know this is a Byzantine
environment a real assumption of miners
or maybe incentives that aren't hidden
is there some kind about kind of
incentives you know there is something
about here or you just have a step
function in a sense of ease that's good
that's a good question
I have to check this offline but you
could imagine trying to extend the
results by saying you only want civil
proof in this among rational parties and
you only want collusion proof in this
among rational parties and you don't
care what the other people do it's
possible something similar would be true
but I'd have to go through it there's
some kind of cost doing this mining pool
right and miners have different levels
of risk aversion so have you thought
about how those different levels of risk
aversion might influence whether miners
want to join in this way or not if
someone could make more money in the
long term by deviating that's a good
question I think that question probably
becomes particularly interesting when
you have multiple mining pools and
you're thinking about how do people
decide which one to join
right I mean so here so here in the pool
version the degree of your risk aversion
actually no longer matters in the limit
right if you're getting deterministic
Google Ward's there's no uncertainty
that preferred not prefer right so
there's gonna be some like transaction
for you which I'm sort of ignoring sure
so I mean I guess in a sense you could
you know if it was costless to bring it
into the chain you could say this is
eliminating the middleman and now people
would strictly prefer actually to just
go direct to the protocol as opposed to
a mining pool for example yeah that was
not in my model but there's no way to
avoid the cost even if you don't have
another one
that's true I think it's competing
chains for example a miner wouldn't make
more an achievement
situations where people are just the
opposite where they really preferred
risk yep yep yep yeah that's true so I
actually I was tempted to put this on
the slide but I didn't so I'm glad you
brought it up so there's also the notion
of a risk seeking of agent which just
means you was convex instead of concave
and in fact the uniqueness result is
still true for risk seeking miners
actually so it's really risk aversion
that breaks it
great oh my goodness all right so a tiny
bit about again incentive compatibility
that's kind of the mantra but this time
in the context of mining pools directly
studying mining pools and specifically
we're going to be looking at a single
mining pool and incentives for the
participants to report or not report
partial and full solutions we've already
talked a lot about mining pools I think
I'll skip it this is the usual
distribution the Bitcoin mining pools
circuit yesterday I want to think about
implementations which are along the
lines of what we talked about in the
first part of the talk where miners
report both so-called partial solutions
and full solutions full solutions are
what you really want so that's going to
be you know like a block which can be
added to the Bitcoin blockchain right
now you know the hash has at least 75
trailing zeros or whatever now when the
pool okay so the pool has a bunch of
miners working together striving to find
a full solution when a full solution is
found everybody celebrates right the
pool gets to kind of get the block
reward and then distributed somehow the
incentives it's it's intuitive that you
wanted to ship it in a way that
encourages people to bring as much
mining power to the pool as possible but
how do you measure how much mining power
someone brought to the pool well that's
what you use the partial solutions for
okay so those are just solutions to an
easier version of the crypto puzzle so
you want at most sixty-five trailing
zeros of the hash so now if you're a
non-trivial miner even if you're not the
lucky one that finds the full solution
you'll find a bunch of partial solutions
along the way and you have the
opportunity to show you work to report
those partial solutions to the pool who
can then use that in determining what
fraction of the block reward you get
okay so I'm gonna use capital D to
denote the difficulty between the easy
and hard versions of the crypto puzzle
so in between two different full
solutions you know which really do
authorize a block
we're expecting D partial solutions in
between
and again question and you won't
surprise you now to hear that I want to
know what are the incentive compatible
ways of doing this okay again I'm going
to look at that question quite narrowly
I'm going to think about just a single
pool so there's no pool hopping or
anything like that and I want to think
about the only two strategies that a
miner has is they can either report all
of their solutions full and partial
immediately or they can do it with
holding attack I'm only going to address
with holding attacks okay your intuition
may say why would you ever withhold a
share a solution in any reasonable
mining pool but we'll see that even with
very natural ways of doing it you do not
have even this form of incentive
compatibility so this definition is
already interesting to ask about when
you have it and when you don't so what's
the design space well think of it as
basically the same as the first part
although we'll go a little bit beyond
this if there's time so you know so in
an epoch a number of partial solutions
come in followed by a full solution for
now let's think about reward functions
where the reward depends only on the
number of partial solutions contributed
by each of the miners this is throwing
out some information that the mining
pool has like for example the order in
which they were reported but for now
let's just accept that get there's
plenty of natural rules where you only
look at the partial solution counts okay
and by the way a full solution counts as
a partial solution as well so within
this family okay that do not depend on
the ordering of the reports just on the
on the numbers on the counts you
actually can give a exact
characterization of which reward
functions or incentive compatible and
which ones are not
I'm not so this is in the paper I'm
gonna administer time I'm gonna skip
this and instead I'm gonna move on to
some specific reward functions which are
very natural
some of which are incentive compatible
and some of which are not okay and just
know that in the background there's some
general condition which tells you one
when such a function is incentive
compatible and when it is it
yes I'm assuming you have a sunk cost as
far as your mining equipment yeah so
you're just new they're your machines
are on you're gonna leave them on and
the question is just what do you do with
what you find correct yeah so there's no
no nothing about investment or effort
it's not they're still coasting what I
wasted for yeah so the reason the delay
is not to save on electricity cost or
something it's going to come from other
other places okay so I think what will
be easier to understand is some concrete
examples some of which are icy some of
which are not okay but there is a
general characterization if you want it
so one very natural thing is exactly the
same allocation rule the reward function
we're talking about in the first part
proportional so the so that you know
eventually a full solution comes in and
terminates the epoch and so here the
mining pool looks at the number of
partial solutions contributed by
everybody and splits the block reward
accordingly
is this incentive compatible
well perhaps counter-intuitively the
answer is no actually this is not
incentive compatible and it's a little
bit subtle so let me sort of slowly
explain why
remember wouldn't send a compatible
means that means whenever you find a
partial solution you should report it
whenever you find a full solution you
should report it immediately there's no
problem with partial solutions if you
ever find a partial solution and you
delay it the only thing that can happen
is you might get scooped someone else
might find a full solution terminating
the epoch and your partial solution is
lost okay so there's no upside there's a
downside partial partial solutions not a
problem so it's really about full
solutions so to think about this I want
you to think about all of the solutions
reported by all the miners in this pool
partial and full over some period of
time okay this is once in a while a full
solution we expect there to be capital D
say let's say a thousand partial
solutions between each consecutive pair
of full solutions okay now of course
some of them will be bigger some of them
will be smaller just that just out of
the variance now here's the question I
want you to think about right so we have
a bunch of epochs in a row suppose I
told you exactly one of these partial
solutions is yours do you care which one
it is
yes you do your routing that your
partial solution happens to be in one of
the unusually short epochs with not many
other partial solutions that's because
it's the proportionate allocation rule
all right so if you're a super you're in
an epoch that has only ten different
partial solutions you get 10% of the
reward as opposed to if you were in a
typical one that had a thousand so
that's an observation all else being
equal miners prefer to have their
partial solutions appear in short blocks
okay so how can you take advantage of
that well now suppose you're happily
mining away okay and you find a full
solution moreover you find a full
solution very early within an epoch
because you're expecting a thousand
partial solutions to be found before a
full solution but you find one after
only a hundred partial solutions have
been reported you have the option of
reporting the full solution immediately
that would terminate the epoch start a
new one new epochs so any partial share
that then you then report fine later
will belong to a new epoch which has
expected length capital D so the partial
solutions you that compute in the future
will have an expectation a payoff of 1
over capital D that's if you report a
media but what else could you do you
could say you know what let me stay
quiet I'm gonna wait till there's 200
partial solutions reported and only at
that point will I report my full
solution
how is that helpful alright basically
what that does is it smuggles
whatever partial solutions you would
have found at the beginning of the next
epoch and brings them back into the
current short epoch okay so whatever
parts of solutions you would have found
in the first hundred slots of the next
epoch now all of a sudden because you've
delayed your reporting it's actually in
this current epoch which is still going
and this epoch is short okay even after
the extra 100 you're only weighting 200
slots factor of five better than the
average so you're super happy that
you've got that you've smuggled these
partial shares from a sort of typical
block into a block that you know is
short so that's the base that's the
that's what really drives the failure of
incentive compatibility there's other
details you have to take into account so
there's also the risk that you get
scooped that someone else finds the full
solutions you have to incorporate that
turns out it also matters you know what
fraction of the current partial shares
are yours
compared to your hash rate but there are
settings of all of these parameters so
that indeed you are strictly
incentivized to weights as opposed to a
media reporting of a full solution
right where I just want to keep going
until I see that someone else might
block broadcast - dr. grace right so
this is even this is even orthogonal to
a selfish man attack yeah I mean you
sort of need the I mean we'd be at the
pool level but you Dex acute the selfish
mining attack I think most effectively
so that's exactly the reason you would
hold well you're working on the same
crypto puzzles before right so the new
partial shares you're trying to generate
are still for that same crypto puzzle so
it's not so you're not tricking anyone
else into solving the wrong problem so
that's kind of a basic difference I
would say yeah ok good so not incentive
compatible could anything be incentive
compatible well yeah sure consider the
paper share reward function where the
payment you get for a partial solution
is just fixed what do you fix it at well
for example you could fix it at the
amount so that the expected payout in an
epoch is equal to the reward you have to
pay out it's a 1 here there's really no
reason to ever delay okay it's all
downside the only thing the only change
that could happen is that your partial
solution gets invalidated by someone
scooping it
it was definitely incentive compatible
the obvious weakness is that it is only
budget balanced in expectation okay in
short epochs this pool will run a profit
and long epochs this pool will run a
deficit okay
the expectations are okay but it's not
guaranteed to be budget balanced epic by
epic and actually if you think about it
there's actually a pretty serious
sabotage attack against this as well
okay because of the expected budget
balance property so that leads us to the
natural question can we get the best of
both worlds
okay incentive compatibility like we
have in pay per share and guaranteed
budget balance like we have in the
proportional rule and so this paper I
forgot to say so this is joint work with
Dan Bonet who's at Stanford Joba know at
NYU and oka scribers who's at Facebook
okay there's a period and financial
crypto a few years ago so that paper
includes a proposal for getting both for
getting both IC and budget balance and
it's very simple
which scheme of the two we've seen so
far that when an epoch starts you start
out doing pay per share
okay just pay one over D for each
partial solution that you see if you get
to the point where you are about to run
a deficit if you've seen capital D
partial solution so far you flip a
switch and you change over to
proportional
so proportional was not I see so why
should this be I see when the paper
share part is fine okay no incentive
issues there but remember the whole
reason proportional failed to be I see
was because miners wanted to smuggle
shares in the blocks that they knew were
going to be short
we only switch over to the proportional
rule when we know the block is going to
be long this gonna be D or more so that
incentive goes away because the current
block is guaranteed to be long there's
no reason to not report immediately
that's where IC comes from there's an
obvious complaint that this is not
budget balanced it's only weekly budget
balanced in short epochs the pool will
run a profit so you don't like that if
you want to if you want strong exact
budget balance you need to somehow we
redistribute that residual reward as
well one way not the only way one way
you could do that if you wanted would be
anything left on the table the residual
prize you could give that to the miner
who reported the full solution and ended
the epoch for example it's again not a
perfect solution because now you've
reintroduced some of the variants you
were trying to get rid of but it's still
the case in this hybrid scheme that you
know roughly 65% of the rewards or so
gets smoothed out just as well as they
wouldn't any other mining pool alright
so I think I'm put the open questions on
the slide but otherwise I think I'm out
of time and I'll stop there
[Applause]
or exactly made all these partial things
the same but you never gave more or
giving the full thing and you can
imagine something between where you kind
of get more zeroes I have to think about
it that's that's a very nice suggestion
they have sort of you know as many
levels of difficulty as you want yeah no
see right so I mean in this model the
assumption is all you have or partial
shares and full shares and so it would
enrich the design space to use more
information possibly in an interesting
way Oh good question
no that's a very natural question that
we did not do that the question was did
we analyze you know so all I showed you
was a failure of incentive compatibility
the only claim was there exist
situations where it's strictly better to
withhold than the report immediately and
a ties question was can you quantify how
much more which is types of questions I
really like to study but we didn't study
that for this paper last and shares has
some of the similar problems is
proportional actually there's again some
there's some incentive compatibility
issues with paper last name it's related
so it's again it's a little we talk
about it offline it's a little technical
but part of what's going wrong with
proportional is also going wrong with
paper last end shares
the first part of the dog the way he
used that it was yes so that in the
first part the the theorem would hold
for any proof of stake system if the way
that you distribute rewards depends only
on the current stakes as opposed to some
richer function of the protocol history
like whether you bought you know how to
you know stake something in the past but
if you think about it like the input to
our reward function was just the hash
rates I didn't give you the information
to talk about the history sure yeah so
right so even in proof of work context
the assumption here is that you're using
only the hash rates of this epoch to do
the reward redistribution that's really
the key I guess I would just saved that
so I think you're right that's probably
a more natural assumption and the proof
of where context and proof state context
but right it's not proof of what proof
of stake per se that's a good point
what happened the second part it's
essentially there is this notion of
incidence random variable when you come
to some process and the process itself
has intervals okay if the intervals are
all the same size then you don't care if
the intervals a variation you expect the
time until the end
that's what's essentially yeah it's a
little like an optimal stopping problem
or something what was the name that you
said
Thanks
[Applause]